hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lame waifu
and today we have a whole lot of
emotions to process or more specifically
they have a whole lot of emotions to
process so let's get into it because
it's all kind of icky
really as expected meruem is alive and
well whoa well he's being taken care of
by his
royal guard by which i mean he's being
taken care of
by his royal guard this show can be so
very strange in the way it handles
sexually derived content and exactly
when it turns up the artistically
beautiful metaphorical orgasms of the
royal guard made the situation very
clear and i don't really know how to
explain that situation other than noting
that it was a scene entirely worthy of
he saw car the crashing waves the gasps
and
moans and blissful staring into nowhere
the eyes freed from the bonds of the
universe it was all a great metaphor for
the sacrifice of
self to the greater good yes and i got
that don't think i missed it because it
was very
very clear but the sacrifice very
clearly didn't end pouf's life
entirely instead it reduced him to the
one clone but didn't mean he couldn't be
the size he would be otherwise
he gave his essence to the creature he
cares most about because that
to him is loyalty up not to be outdone
became the happiest
satyr alive since mr tumnus sang lucy to
sleep and you know what the comparison
with the lion the witch and the wardrobe
sort of works because while he gives of
himself to meruem on the one side
poof's betraying him like an edmund on
the other so he can have all that
merome delight to himself the jealousy
in proof size
when you pee when you pee when you pee
pours his essence in tomorrow m's mouth
is all we really need to say on the
topic to know how per feels about the
situation it's frankly lucky that mary
thought of both flavors
as unique but perfect because a fight
would have immediately broken out
because poof must be the tastiest
of i just it was interesting the casual
nature of perf offering himself to the
king at first i thought it was going to
be an entire sacrifice but then it
wasn't at all and i wonder whether mary
will ever want to eat human again
he has yet to have found a human he
liked the taste of unlike his mother
he has a more refined palette he only
wants to eat
technically his siblings and their
children maybe so
what will that do to his desire to rule
the world the art of this sequence was
very focused on the sensations involved
in reviving mary and while that
is powerful the whole feeding thing was
freaking weird and i feel like maybe a
little too much time was spent on the
orgasmic organic nature of it given the
erotic historical connotations involved
with both fairies and satyrs
i i am not surprised that mary enjoyed
the situation i'm not surprised he
didn't remember much of it and i'm not
surprised that this was the reaction
they had i just wasn't expecting to
spend my morning watching an animated
metaphorical representation of a
threesome you know now that mary knows
that these
fluids are the best fluids and we have
seen the plumping of his cells i'm sorry
i don't know how else to describe these
things and i don't know how to move on
it was most of the episode oh and it was
odd to me that when the metaphors came
in they were human cherubs
not ant cherubs was that to ensure we
got the point without extra comedy was
it because we wouldn't understand the
intention
if it went that far or was it because
that's how mary experiences bliss or the
concept of heaven
things to think about now for now meruem
finally has a connection with his mother
because he has a connection with his
name
and as a result he has a connection with
his goal beyond destruction and what he
aim to do and he's shared it whether he
knows that or not call me by my name he
said and so they will
naterro died for nothing or in fact he
died to make meruem stronger as the
narrator says
mary died and was reborn something that
wasn't lost on me
or on the guard he's no longer their
king he's their deity
was he always i'm not sure i don't think
so
i think his rebirth elevated him in
their eyes which i wouldn't have thought
was possible but
seems to have happened i suppose they're
smaller now and he's bigger
so technically he has been elevated in
their eyes his amnesia is an interesting
development because it does give perth
the chance to betray his god and i
wouldn't be surprised if mary knows what
he tries to do
i sense a disturbance in the ant force
sharing the thoughts of the king
is great until now i thought the ants
had been sharing thoughts the way the
rest of the colony would
through that telepathy situation but
mary being born early may have stood in
the way
now he's been reborn at the right time
and will be even more difficult to stop
because he's come into his full power as
given by his royal guard
it's interesting to me that it's
apparently possible to give nen and yet
humans haven't considered that kind of
sacrifice
another difference between ants and
humans the abilities have been shared
because he consumed a part of them
and it didn't need to be in its entirety
i don't know it seems like the sort of
thing killer would do giving gon some of
his ability
just to do that and be the best i don't
know
killa would do that though kilo was the
type the next step is to learn how long
marouane feels confusion whether perf
can get to kamugi before
mary does is an interesting prospect i
wouldn't be surprised if it's not the
palace
mary is headed toward but komugi the
palace has answers
does it or does kamugi following pito's
healing could perth even hurt kamugi she
hasn't opened her eyes fully and it's
interesting because we've never seen her
standing in comparison to anyone and in
the previous episode she seemed taller
than i've ever seen her before she's
also being called a woman hinting at my
expectation that she's going to be his
queen
she misses him and she cares for him if
nothing else it's kind of cute to think
that that's where it's
all going even if he just rips her head
off when he sees her like that's totally
love you know
some bugs do that but it's usually the
other way around maybe she'll rip his
head off
the oracle has seen the king and they
now know that the king comes to claim
his
throne or his bride who knows i don't
let's check out episode 1 29 episode 129
and mary's abilities are clearly
increasing
in the way of the chimera ants which he
is
so that sounds weird but in the way of
the chimera ants
meruem consuming others allows him to
gain their abilities however he doesn't
do it the way others do he gains
abilities by
essentially becoming one with them
sharing emotions with them it's the hive
mind concept which i like
and an evolution on what they had before
in the past they were able to
communicate with each other
telepathically without speaking
something that became very clear or at
least seems clear to me is the idea that
they couldn't know the king's mind they
had no way of knowing what marowan was
thinking
and he'd never to my knowledge chosen to
share his thoughts with any other ants
he was perfectly inscrutable if he
didn't raise an eyebrow or thwack than
with his tail there was no way of
knowing how he felt about things but now
they can feel his emotions and now he
has emotions that he wants to share
one of the great things to come of this
episode for me was the idea that the
ants display a great deal of empathy
understanding and thoughtfulness mary
sets boundaries like no other character
in this show
he says what he means and expects no
more than what he sets down as an
expectation to begin with i'm not saying
they or he
are necessarily good just that they're
clear there's an acceptance of their own
failures an acceptance of consequences
that just don't seem to apply to the
humans in the series
or at least the humans don't seem
willing to consider in any deep and
meaningful way
when perth lies to mary merowem stamps
that out with a quickness that makes it
clear he has expectations of those who
share his mind
meanwhile yupi considerate of the
experiences he's had and the ways in
which
it's changed him is closer to meruem in
that understanding of the three
perf is very clearly the one frozen in
humanity
rather than communicating how important
her death is to the king
perv assumes meruem isn't as intelligent
as he is and tries to outsmart him which
in itself could be considered traitorous
you know what i loved about this episode
was how clearly frantic perf is becoming
around making sure mary doesn't remember
kamugi the idea that meroem has a
duality to him is something that perf is
entirely missing and the series of lies
is going to get him
killed no matter what he does at this
point from what marowan was saying i
have a strong expectation that he wants
to find the part of him that hurts
and sacrifice it the use of the word
sacrifice is an interesting one too
because to sacrifice something
you have to appreciate its value
otherwise it's butchery right
we sacrifice sacred things they come
from the same root word i guess
i think i didn't look it up but they
have the same sack
so they come from the same root word in
in my
in my definition of the word so komugi
is sacred and perfe is essentially
trying to erase her existence before
mary can connect with it again
the back and forth is particularly
fascinating because eventually meruem
will connect those dots
if not through komugi's physical
existence then through the emotion he
and perf share
because emotions in themselves can
prompt memories if we feel sad we can
think of all the other times we felt sad
and feel worse
if we feel happy we try to memorize the
feeling forget kamooki even
what happens when meroem sees an eagle
when he sees a woman with her eyes
closed when he hears the click of a cane
on the ground
perf can't hide the truth from marowan
but he recognizes consciously or not
that in a state of amnesia the king is
vulnerable to mindset shifts
a really dangerous prospect frankly his
obsession with kamuki and
desperation to get things on track to
his own standards is entirely counter to
marowan's needs and it shows a lack of
trust in the rebirth king
not to mention the fact that while perth
was explaining meroem's recent history
he used heavily charged language
designed to influence him
unlike youpi whose turns of phrase don't
hide anything but they also don't
hyperbolize anything
i actually think that marowen would be a
better king than most
of the monarchs in existence now
here because of the simplicity with
which he handles situations
his willingness to accept emotional
instability and traitorousness to a
point proves that he
expects ants to show the humanity that
is a part of them but to be cognizant of
how they're interpreting it
basically he offers perth the chance to
come clean and perth doesn't take it i
can't see a world in which
perf and camogie both survive they're
opposite sides of the same coin now
meanwhile kilwa's electrical skills are
grown by the zap i love the idea of him
as a bug zapper catching a moth and the
proclamation that he can go all night is
an interesting one
in context of the last episode and given
that he ran out of electricity the first
time
his art in all of this is beautiful in
fact the entire sequence between he
komugi and perf was beautifully visually
narrated
because we have kamugi's softened
features
and closed eyes trying to make sense of
the sharpness of the other two
of course perf's words would affect her
the only thing she wants is the ruler
she trusts
if i heard all that with my eyes closed
i would think i was being taken hostage
too and it's close to the truth after
all there's something wildly beautiful
in puff getting more and more desperate
as meruem reveals that he doesn't care
about the palace
it's not about the palace it never was
about the palace it's kamoogie who is
important to him and perf wouldn't have
considered it nor could he
understand meruem's pain or the task set
out by the ant queen why
because he doesn't feel love he's not
feeling that love he's feeling
manipulation he's feeling control
or lack of it he's losing control of the
situation and that is what he's feeling
the whole point is for meruem to find
something to breed with and continue the
improvement of their species
and now perth's getting in the way of
that purpose the king values her the
king values her
the sacrifice perf isn't lying not about
that she's sacred
he just doesn't know in which way just
like kite who i imagine would be
horrified at what god has become but
that's not something i know it's
something i want to know and to know it
i have to watch the next episode so
that's it from me
if you enjoyed this discussion on
moralistic tendencies and ant capacity
for emotion and etymology and entomology
and all of the e
words i guess click here here and here
hit the bell
and i'll see you next time